good to have you here Joe Buck in person
sir good to be here I love it here
I love your little neck of the woods
it's it's impressive it gets bigger it
gets more interactive every time I come
here they're more games it's it's like a
Chuckie Cheese well you know what
without the cheese without the cheese
and without Chuck I know you should have
it like an animatronic band over there
of weird things moving making awful
music yeah by the way that's what those
guys are animatronic over there Chris
and Mike are our kind of animatronic
well Chris looks fantastic whoever made
del two foes way off because he doesn't
look like that watch that's the cleanest
version of del to go over there good the
intimidating gigantic stomp around del 2
foe I know I'm not sure yeah I just call
the game I am there for the X's and O's
come there for the first downs and
touchdowns you know what it's it's
robots not on my watch it's funny having
done Thursday Night Football for about
12 years before you know you surfed in
and the first two games are absolutely
fantastic yeah dick Ulis off the charts
the first game was appoints extravaganza
between Cincinnati and Baltimore which
by the way as you know never is right
never is yeah
Dalton's throwing touchdowns like it's a
Sunday afternoon not like it's a
Thursday night I know he's usually he
struggled in prime time let's say that
until you showed up well I don't think I
have anything to do with it maybe it's a
Quinn maybe it's it's the little fox
banner that shows up and then the crazy
game that we had and Cleveland's
unbelief that was like a Super Bowl and
being in that Stadium was was one of the
coolest feelings I've had I'm I don't
know is it ridiculous to say in my
career because it just was like there
was such a relief and there was so much
excitement just that this guy we finally
got the guy and he delivered and he
looked good doing it it wasn't like he
just lucked into a win I mean he made it
happen
and and you called World Series Indians
World Series games in Cleveland yeah so
yeah you've been
Cleveland for some euphoric and they
blame me for the Indians losing to the
Cubs always the guy calling it fault the
problem is I call it more than other
people call it so therefore it's usually
my fault
so Mayfield coming in I'm sitting at
home I felt it through the television
set what in the world was it like in
that stadium well you know we talked
about it early because it felt like the
sand was running out of the hourglass
for Tyrod Taylor because he really
wasn't playing well then he goes down
and he gets hurt so you know it's coming
but III wonder what the story would have
been had he not gotten hurt and how many
more series he would have had I think he
was about finished anyway and then
Mayfield comes in and you could just
feel this swell of emotion but then then
you see him play and watch him throw it
I was not aware I didn't see him a ton
in college I was not aware that he had
that kind of velocity that he had that
arm strength the way he was you know
really slinging it into tight spots you
know he's he's a leader type a rah-rah
guy and the tools to back it all up and
then you know the button pushed to have
I guess the Cleveland special called for
him to catch the touchdown now that's
the way to fire that's Todd Haley I
think if the nation learned anything
during hard knocks it was how kind of
funny and irreverent and whatever Todd
Haley is and and he ends up yeah running
this same type play that Philly ran in
the Superbowl and he catches right here
he catches a Tut this is just good
action by you guys is a two-point
conversion here it is it ties the game
lefty throwing Jarvis Landry yeah who
knew that I mean the whole thing it
really was just incredible to watch and
unfold and the Jets just didn't have the
pass rush to get Adam I mean what we're
cuz they it's amazing how football and
AI sports in general works is that 13
days before just not even 10 days before
in Detroit they were the Harlem
Globetrotters right and then that
night they were the Washington Generals
just like playing along with the
narrative so we get a review of our
games by somebody some unnamed producer
that sends us a review of all of our
games and the the criticism of us
internally was that it became a Brown
centric broadcast and and I think
there's some truth to that you know at
the end you walk out of there and you go
man did we even talk about the Jets you
know because once Baker Mayfield came in
it was like you're counting down the
time until Mayfield comes back out on
the field meanwhile you got Sam darn old
and you know all that he brings in the
Jets offensively so I'm sure Jets fans
blame me that that they lost that game
we didn't talk enough about the Jets but
I think they're right if they add that
complaint well speaking on behalf of all
jet fans you bastard Joe yeah no so
you're a lucky bastard that's the name I
mean someday bless you someday I would
love to see my book up there without
Michaels I mean as Al Michaels been on
as many times as I have I don't think so
does Al Michaels have pictures of you
and Suzy when we both had more hair in
front of a birthday cake I don't think
so
this is your show do they are they in
charge of their little nook over there
that's the essence arduous little nook
over there that my first show on Fox
Sports Net I mixed Joe called going deep
I think you should send me one
autographed to me and I'll put it right
oh so it has to be a flabby to did I'll
send you that you got a free one now on
the show Joe I'm the king of free come
on don't fit now
ain't nothing that you're wearing right
now something you paid for yes anything
pants see there you go does that make
you feel better how do we even know he's
wearing pants by the way you're not
wrong okay you absolutely does not even
sure my books in print anymore yes there
are any I will Joe Buck it's something I
just you said that I want to pick up on
so some producer at Fox writes up a
critique of the Thursday Night Football
broadcast you do not know who this
person is do not it's sort of like it's
uh I think it's I'm great I if I were
running a network I'd do the same thing
because as you know
rarely or maybe when you do a studio
show it's different but when you do a
game it just kind of comes and goes even
a Super Bowl and you don't know there's
no scoreboard nobody says hey you know
you're really great game today you'll
one you just kind of leave and when
somebody bothers to watch the game you
know they're critiquing all of it from
the music placement to the graphic to
Troy you know whatever his comment was
or Aaron down in the field I love it
because it gives you feedback and and
most of the time it's from somebody
inside the business that gives you
something that you can really learn from
and now you're here in Los Angeles big
game this is a huge one week for now
this is one that's on Fox NFL Network
and Amazon Prime you know you get the
whole triple cast of the first time yeah
on bigs like the Olympics right so this
Rams team is ridiculous
offensively unbel mean they just they're
loaded and you know you then you look at
the defense and they bring in sue and
Peter's and to leave and they can fit
all this in and they can re-up Aaron
Donald and they can you know sign cooks
to a contract extension so you know they
went through that period where they
really had to get rid of some players
and now they've built it up I mean if
they're not the best team in the NFC I
don't know who is and right now after
three weeks you're looking at Kansas
City and the AFC this just looks like
world beaters and the Rams in the NFC
but but we've got a Vikings team coming
into this game that's so good
defensively coming off one of the most
head-scratching games I've ever
witnessed we were doing a game or we
were kind of getting ready for a game
and that score came in I was like what
mmm how is that possible but you know
good for Josh Allen good for the bills
and I know from reading the clips that
these Vikings are ready to get back out
there and kind of get that taste of it
yeah I mean that was unreal I had
cousins was turning the ball over the
bills were all over them LeSean McCoy
didn't even play the Vikings looked
nothing like the Super Bowl contenders
that we thought they were and that they
did look like for the first two weeks of
the season and now they're coming in and
there is no Talib or Peters for Thursday
Night Football as they are hurt sir
this is a dig stealing situation on
Thursday night it better I think it
better be you know I think if you go
into a game against the Rams you better
be able to put up some points
I mean they've gone there over 30 each
of the first three weeks yeah I just
don't I I don't see anybody shutting
them down they're gonna have to limit
them the Vikings and they're gonna have
to try and match them on the scoreboard
which I think they can do you know like
you said injuries and I'm anxious to see
Cousins play in in purple and you have
seen the Cowboys play twice now the
opener against Carolina and then the one
that you just referenced the game where
you were seeing that score coming in
Seattle with the Cowboys and Seattle
having seen them and sitting next to
Troy what what is their malfunction to
be one and two after what we saw Sunday
night as well it's the offensive line I
mean III know that they don't have the
dynamic guy on the outside Dez Bryant's
gone Jason Witten is gone doing the
stuff over the middle and and they miss
those guys but they miss those guys when
they were in their prime certainly more
des than than Jason I think Jason kind
of went out on top but when you lose
Travis Frederick the center who's the
all-pro in the middle of all that and
then you have a rookie at left guard who
you know can play and is good but is
gonna get better there there are holes
on that offensive line so there's not as
much room for Elliott to run they're not
really protecting dak Prescott who's
trying to find guys to get open so to me
and and to Troy you know that that
offensive line has gone from the best in
the NFL you know now because of this
situation with Travis Frederick with
guillain-barre syndrome which is you
know an autoimmune disease they don't
know when or if he'll come back so it's
it's that to me is the central problem
and then now you start mixing baseball
in with the NLCS is that what the NLCS
so I don't do baseball till the NLCS and
then the World Series and in both the
travel days Thursday so all I'll mix
football back in during the travel day
so it's gonna be a crazy month of
October a good time to have five month
old twins they're gonna look at me like
I'm sorry you're who your
and we've got a routine please leave now
well they'll they'll see you on TV yeah
you know they'll pop your TV just make
sure they don't think Troy's are dead
that's all yeah there's so many jokes
that I could I know that I don't even
know why I said this yeah
Broncos it card what if Roy is their dad
I mean think of the possibilities
Michelle is a great athlete yes Troy is
you know number one overall pick in 1989
I mean one of these two boys or both
could be incredible athletes I think I
would accept that but do do they and you
could but you could tell this right now
do they have a good set of pipes you can
tell them right now one of them cries
like you can't believe the other ones
just kind of looking at me like you know
okay dance
so ounce having these boys anywhere as
you have has anybody blame them for
anything that was not their fault
publicly no yet so maybe they're not
your children could be you know there
are a lot of questions we've we've
raised more questions than come up with
answers on this appearance on the Rich
Eisen show that's sad that's what
happens here so I'm taking a look on
October 18th
that's an NLCS the Thursday date Arizona
at Arizona so they're sliced
slip-sliding away right very good
reference day Paul Simon and then the
Houston Texans there you go that's
during the World Series potentially
right yeah the Dolphins at the Texas is
a Thursday night I mean this could be
Deion Sanders 2.0 get in that helicopter
get in the helicopter just land go do
the game I try did that once in San
Francisco I did a 49er game and then
took a trolley car come on - I did this
happened in 2012 to a baseball game and
did the Giants Cardinals in the
postseason and we're on this trolley and
Fox is shooting it like it's a police
chase like it was like the OJ Simpson
thing on the highway the slope and
they're slow but the trolley car is
going and I talked to the driver I'm
like is this is this thing only go six
miles an hour
and he's like no it goes up to 50 I said
well the games about to start
finally we started going we had a police
escort that wouldn't do anything because
they were scared about the the look of
having a police escort for me going to
the game so it was just it was I got
into the booth literally within 10
minutes of the first pitch so there was
a police escort with you on a cable car
trolley in San Francisco six on the
highway you remember everything I'm sure
that we could sounds really not
compelling what is it you must have felt
like totally ridiculous
I felt like a complete jerk and then I'm
walking through the Giants fans they
think I hate the Giants cuz they're
playing the Cardinals I'm like putting
my coat over my head dodging things and
running for my life got to the booth
breathless I fling the door open
McCarver's looking at me like thank God
you finally made it in here and then I
look in the corner of the booth and
Daron Sutton's sitting there in a coat
and tie like drop them on he was waiting
as the stand if I didn't make it yeah
and I made it within 10 minutes of the
first pitch and I look over I didn't
know that part they didn't tell me that
and I look over I'm like oh hey Darin
how are you got in there huh they had
him there I was proud of Fox if they had
a plan B he was like why am i blanking
on Peyton Manning's backup right now Jim
sore gu no no no in Denver big tall dude
that goes nowhere oh wow yeah my blanket
never Osweiler thought he was coming to
the game one time yeah but Manning was
out in this case just tie off and walked
out of the booth Fox called it part
Steve McQueen part Rose Bowl parade just
get off the internet will ya how do
these guys get a mic now no they do hi
that's the mic I'm just kidding I yeah
it was it was not it let's just say
didn't deliver the Big Bang they thought
they thought it would deliver and here's
video of
you're in the front seat with the
trolley driver got an MLB crew following
your yeah there's traffic like the worse
there's traffic there's not supposed to
be traffic it's the worst Benny Hill
opening so you got Vikings at Rams this
Thursday Colts at Patriots following
Thursday that won't be interesting
won't be any discussion of the footballs
in that on that pregame or throughout
that game right yeah no there will be no
that just dawned on you coltd Patriots
that it was deflategate possible I don't
think about that you go week to week
Eagles of Giants Broncos at Cardinals
Dolphins detection so I would daresay
now it's a game yeah now it's a game
Godspell Joe those Godspell very good do
you want to answer before you let you go
though it's one-hit-wonder day national
one-hit wonder day okay you have your
favorite one-hit wonder I still think
the greatest song of all time as we
built this city but I don't know that
they're really one hit one but start the
shame ban I know and by the time they
got to putting out we built this city
they were that was it that's true
nothing nothing's gonna stop us now that
was the same starship it's just starship
we built this city I'm not getting into
this Joe Buck with a drinking wonder as
we go out to do whatever's an airplane
then they were Jefferson Starship she's
evidently Jefferson law left Joe Buck
good to see you good to see you good to
see all you guys yes thank you it's it's
almost that time of year where they just
blow it up and take a screenshot of
their TV and let's master that I I don't
know why do people look at that stuff on
the internet you son of a and then bring
it up on a Rose Bowl parade the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience